pour conclure cette édition le retour
sur terre dans les steppes du kazakhstan
de l'équipe russe qui a tourné un film à
bord de la station spatiale
internationale de bon sens ainsi le
projet de tournage américain avec le
célèbre acteur tom cruise la
correspondance en russie signé verhaeghe
hoffman depuis le centre de contrôle des
vols spatiaux russes
12 jours en orbite et c'est désormais
l'heure du retour l'équipe du film le
défi lé réalisateur clint shipping co
l'actrice eut 2-6 accompagné d'un
cosmonaute professionnels allègue david
qui vient d'intégrer la ddt dans les
steppes du kazakhstan nous avons pu tout
voir ici sur le grand écran le centre du
contrôle des vols spatiaux le vol depuis
la station spatiale internationale a
pris presque quatre heures soit à peu
près le temps d'un vol paris moscou en
avion plus de 200 militaires 12
hélicoptères trois avions une vingtaine
de véhicules spéciaux ont été affrétés
pour accueillir la capsule soyouz à son
retour sur la terre ferme la première
étape pour les cosmonautes après
l'atterrissage c'est l'examen médical on
nous dit que l'équipage se porte bien la
procédure se fait immédiatement après
l'expression des spationautes de la
capsule pour évaluer leur état de santé
les surcharges ou accélération de la
pesanteur qui couvre les cosmonautes
lors d'une descente standards sont de 4
g ce qui n'est pas beaucoup pour les
cosmonautes professionnels qui
s'entraînent à éprouver des surcharges
allant jusqu'à 9 ou 10 g après l'examen
médical les astronautes doivent
s'envoler pour moscou où ils vont passer
une semaine sous surveillance médicale
dans la cité des étoiles dans la
banlieue de la capitale qui abrite le
centre d'entraînement des cosmonautes
russes
pour rappel il s'agit du premier
équipage cinématographique dans l'espoir
de l'espace du l'impéritie et clim
shipping co tourner un long métrage
racontant l'histoire d'une jeune femme
médecin qui s'envole vers la station
spatiale internationale pour sauver la
vie d'un cosmonaute le tournage a eu
lieu dans le secteur russe mais aussi
dans le secteur américain de la station
spatiale internationale
la sortie du film est prévue pour
l'année 2022